hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen leute zu einem neuen video
hier lest es wahrscheinlich schon titel
und zwar das ist mein neues haustier mir
wurde nämlich so was von häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben lukas spiel doch
mal alpakawolle deswegen befinden wir
uns hier in der mein gott was zum
bittersüß lagen wir klicken direkt mal
aufs datum in die welt rein zu kommen da
seht ihr schon rechts eingeblendet
jackson level 1 das ist nämlich mein
alpaka das hab ich mich haben die kraft
wir können auch jackson drauf klicken
und dann seht ihr schon das ist jackson
jackson der laserattacke oh mein gott
das lockt er richtig richtig filigran
what the [ __ ] jackson research ipo die
ich habe das spiel schon so ein bisschen
selber gibt es oft einfach nur
umzuschauen worum es geht es ist ein
spiel mit in app käufen
also man muss quasi geld investieren um
ein bisschen was zu erreichen ich kann
einfach mal auf kollektive drücken
worden 35
diese kriege ich eine warnung wenn ich
die wolle kollekten will dauernd steht
jetzt fünf stunden bis ich wieder wolle
einsammeln kann hier fünf spielen da
kann ich jackson war jackson dümmste
sportlich und stets einfach nur rum mit
einem süßen hut da oben das ist der
kardex was ich hier machen kann weiß ich
nicht ich kann auf altem rücken habe ich
hier wolle light control item wohl die
habe ich fünfmal ich habe brodelt
[Musik]
wieso bekomme ich immer eine warnung ich
habe ja auch einen rock was ich damit
machen kann weiß ich tatsächlich auch
nicht also ich habe es versucht wirklich
mir das ganze spiel so ein bisschen
beizubringen
er will ich komm nicht klar damit ein
paar sekunden später ich bin jetzt
gerade mal einfach in die city gegangen
und so sieht das ganze hier aus also ich
kann jetzt auch auf sell klicken meine
frau mein gott 320 münzen
ich habe 320 münzen pro wolle bekommen
das heißt mal füllte sind das 1600 ja
jetzt auf jeden fall 2600 münzen und
kann mir damit jetzt glaube ich ein paar
sachen kaufen das heißt nicht jetzt
bei und kaufe mir xl pushen was zum fix
ist dass minecraft oder was es gibt die
möglichkeit sich noch weitere alpakas zu
kaufen und ich kaufe mir jetzt erst mal
wieso ist das pinke alpaca britischen
männlich kann auch jackson verkaufen er
ist immer noch level 1 ich hoffe aber
denkbar einfach hier sondern ein grünes
alpaca für 255 war es natürlich nehme
ich das mit komplett 2 was zum was soll
ich da ja oder nein drücken die nennen
wir das alpaka was ich gerade gekauft
habe chantal teams election locker
flockig kann ich kann teams auswählen
was verhelfen 89 halbzehn app kannst
dass sie vergessen haben irgendwie die
die sachen da rein zu schreiben
hier ist chantal in meiner farm und
jacksons ihr wollt ihr beiden vielleicht
mal jackson ist auf dem weg zur chantal
ich habe jetzt beide in einem team
hinzugefügt ich weiß nicht was das jetzt
soll das seht ihr hier unten hier ist
ein team ruft ihm da ist bringt hat
irgendwas lassen auf jeden fall meine
beiden haustiere und zwar jackson mit
dem hund und chantal wieder ja schon
teil ist tatsächlich noch voller als
jackson nicht kauft jetzt mal einfach
seine elf porschen ich weiß nicht ich
drücke mal auf bike und hey ich hab
jetzt gekauft und jetzt kann ich doch
theoretisch auf jackson gehen dann
aufatmen dann auf konsum
was für ronny an jackson nicht warum
kann er nicht wann keks essen ich kann
auch auf travel gehen und dann alpaka
hill
warum bin ich auf englisch usa kommen
dann vielleicht richtige nie auch nicht
was ist wenn ich auf sprache japanisch
gehe kommt dann auch yao dann ist es in
anderen schrift geschrieben um ein gott
jacksons richtig fix unterwegs hätten
gerade alle da gibt ja mal richtig gas
ich bin jetzt mal wieder in der stadt
angekommen was ist da bin ich auch
upgrade gehe da ist das ist alles
tatsächlich viel zu teuer
ja freunde viele würden sagen ich bin
vielleicht bescheid aber ich habe ihn
auch ein brett das alpaka gekauft das
pinke pinke pinke pinke ist das da
hinten chantal dieser grüne schein
flecker ist chantal da ist finke und
dass jackson
[Musik]
ich verstehe es jetzt nicht da kann ich
mit euch irgendwie spazieren gehen oder
so wie sie das ist für mich relativ
schwer ich kann spiele eigentlich besser
spielen wenn ich sie mir vorher
angeschaut habe allerdings ist es
lustiger wenn ich die spieler noch nicht
kenne und mir nicht alles so wisst ihr
und das ist hier irgendwie ein komisches
ding ich mein ich bin im fleisch ob
upgrade alpaka stopp und ich weiß nicht
genau was ich machen kann
komm ich kaufmann magenta web ein paar
sekunden später ok was es denn was ist
ihr helft mir wieder super weiteren
tolle nachrichten da als wenn ich mit
dem jetzt hier rumlaufen kann ich könnte
heulen star suisse kommt freunde wir
laufen hier
jackson pinky als wenn ich gegen andere
alpakas kämpfen kann jetzt kann ich hier
auch die scheiße benutzen hier konsum ob
und wann soll ich mal mega impact dann
nochmal meteor nochmal meteo alter der
geht das einfach level 14
wie zum fahrzeug den überhaupt besiegen
deshalb genau wie pokémon ich kann jetzt
auch chantal drückt dann kommt schon
talents match stand teil noch ein mega
impact dann macht chantal noch ein
meteor hier drauf und ich glaube mit dem
rob da unten links was ihr da
eingeblendet sät kann ich dann gleich
das als fachkraft fangen das versuche
ich jetzt mal zum abschluss des videos
zu schaffen die dann auch noch ein
bisschen kämpfen macht auf meteora da
macht die jetzt als nächstes media
impact so und dann macht fink die noch
ein meteor und macht finke jetzt noch
mega impact und dann kriegt man noch
mega impact und noch einen mega impact
und von 38 und jetzt versuche ich mal
einen raus zu holen um das für vier
prozent ich bin hoch gelevelt ich kann
jetzt mit denen hier noch ein bisschen
rumlaufen und noch andere alpakas
treffen ich gehe jetzt aber einfach mal
zurück zur farm also das habe ich mir
gerade gekauft und jetzt mit den kämpfen
alle level 2 deswegen will ich jetzt
sagen wenn euch das video vielleicht
trotzdem gefallen hat auch wenn 90
prozent des videos darauf bestanden dass
ich mir überlegt habe wie das ganze ding
funktioniert nicht über eine bewertung
und wenn ihr tipps für ein poker world
als solcher gewünschte datei nicht zockt
ihr es auch texte diallo und in die
kommentare dann kommt vielleicht und
zweiter teil mich hat das spiel nicht so
krass überzeugt aber dass ein patient
einmal nach haustieren nur unsicherheit
da ich jetzt dann nicht mehr lang auch
danach in fähigkeiten sein kann